this is Asher by hey Asher it's my
littlest son my name is Mark his name is
Mark so so Sean you grew up here I grew
grew up in West Virginia I I've known
them for a while about 10 years the
Whitakers
yeah I was born and raised uh basically
on uh Bud Mountain road called Hickory
Ridge
Road and when I was about 4 years old I
had intentially got molested by a guy
and he uh got arrested for it and stuff
but it was me and my
brother and it's just really mentally
and physically ruined my life did he did
it to you and your brother no he didn't
do it to my brother he shoved my brother
my brother tried to stop it my older
brother he's like a year and N months
older than me at the time he was like 5
and a
half and uh I was
four and he had drugged me to a old
abandoned trailer how old was this guy
the guy was 16 and I was 40 years
old it's just mentally and physically
ruined my life
cuz I had uh had accidents and
everything else all through school
I was made fun of through school
and it's it's just people made fun of me
and I was in a couple classes for
reading and writing
and they uh it's just impacted my life
CU of what happened cuz i' I'd use the
bathroom on myself and things like that
because of what happened mhm how old are
you now I'm uh 29 years old and you have
kids I have four four kids you're
married uh currently divorced oh you are
but what was it like growing up here
it's I mean I like it here it's just uh
I don't like going back around where I
was that happened to me and stuff it
just brings back a lot of
memories and uh I just I really don't
like see it's it kind of it messes my
messes me up talking about it honestly
but I mean I I need to let it out cuz a
lot of people don't understand people
don't like to be bullied that's
basically why I I want to try to put a
stop to bullying bu bullying is
tremendously destructive to to a
person's life I don't want my kids to
ever have to face something like that I
mean my dad when this happened to me my
dad was working out of state I was uh
having to stay with my grandparents and
they were like older and I mean they
they went to take a nap and I guess they
didn't think nothing was going to happen
and then it happened
uh it was
[Applause]
that I just I can't hard I can remember
little bits and pieces but I can't
remember full detail of it but I know
that
uh I had to go to a lot of do like
doctor's appointments and like
Huntington and uh above Charleston a lot
like therapy and stuff yeah and I had to
I had to take counseling uh I seen Zed
and Beckley and uh just like all through
school I just got made fun of and they
what were they making fun of you for
well see I had to where I where I was so
where I went through that dramatic thing
I had problems reading and writing and
it kind of like verbally messed me up
like I had to learn how to read and
write again so I was in special ed
classes do you have like a hard time
focusing and concentrating and yes that
that's where uh the problems came from
yeah uh I had to take classes like
through special way for read and writing
to learn how to read and write again
everything's good now but um when that
happened I just called got called
and got made foot of and it messed up
like me like uh having a relationship
with anybody it's like they thought I
was dumb or something yeah you had
friends I had a little bit I had friends
like that was in special EG classes with
me but I just feel like it it's wrong to
sit there and make fun of somebody when
you don't know what they've been through
you know what I'm saying
right
um I never want my kids to have to deal
with
that um and it's even I mean now that
I'm out of school there's still people
that kind of know me from around the
area that's why kind of reason why I
feel like I lost my past job is cuz they
was doing the same thing at my job they
was making fun of me and throwing rocks
at me
and um call me fat a and F and
I see I don't like cuss I try to go to
church um and I reported it and they uh
turned the story around on me and I said
something racial to
somebody so they fired me you lost your
job yeah this is recently recently
because of
this yeah see seems like one the one
problem brings on another problem which
brings on a third and a fourth and a
fifth and it's a whole string of
problems so my life's pretty much been
messed up because of all
that and
it's I mean it gets me all shaken up and
aggravated but I try to stay strong for
all my kids and
um I mean the girl that I vorce which is
his mom um we're trying to work stuff
we're trying to work stuff out she's uh
from Beckley
area so and she's actually somehow kin
to them too the Whitakers or on her
dad's
side but my sister met Brandon and they
got
together it's just been a long road for
me to having to deal with all these
people making fun of me and stuff yeah
this this
region doesn't offer a whole lot of of
opportunities for a young man no they
don't and I mean it's hard cuz I got
four kids and I lose my job for no
reason and and I'm actually one the one
that's getting bullied and picked on and
I get my job taken because of that is
there something in your behavior that
gets you picked on you think no I mean I
work hard and I try to make make a good
work
ethic I think it's just people from my
like past has talked to other people and
then they want to like they want to come
at me judging me and throwing stuff at
me for stuff that happened in my past
when you were a little kid yeah and they
hold like they just want to use it to
taunt me like and I just don't like it
man uh I know but something like that
happening to a young man is it's the
worst thing that can happen to you yeah
and it's
and now that I'm uh without a job I'm
having to struggle I mean I'm on
unemployment but I'm struggling because
people want to be stupid and don't know
how to grow up like they want to call me
stupid but they're making fun of me
that's actually them being
stupid what kind of work were you doing
I was uh trying to be a blaster on the
surface mines
but I don't guess now yeah other than
coal mining what what else is there I've
uh ran for FedEx a couple
times and uh drove and delivered yeah
it's not not a whole lot of jobs here no
not very really wish I just get out of
here honestly
but I just want to be able to work a job
without having to have people pick on me
you know or ring up my past
life I just uh like moving to someplace
that has more opportunity and you start
a new life and a whole new
yeah ccle people want to do it's hard
though cuz I mean I messed up and life I
had I mean I love my kids and stuff and
but it's kind of hard to move on like
move and get going with this many
kids but
changing location yeah you have to think
of your kids' future too yeah cuz I mean
they've already made friends in school
and stuff and I guess they are used to
them I just
but your kids your kids will make new
friends yeah and you have to think of
this young man's future like if he's
when he's 20 years old what's he going
to do for work
right I don't I just want to put a stop
to bullying basically U I feel like
bullying is wrong and I never want to
see nobody go through what I've had to
go through in my life
yeah but I've been coming down here for
25 years and it's not getting any better
no in terms of opportunities and the
lifestyle on the drugs and all that kind
of stuff yeah that's another thing drugs
big people who's on drug I mean I ain't
going to lie when I was 16 uh or 17
years old I tried marijuana but that's
the only thing that I've ever done in my
life that's correct besides that I mean
I used to drink a little bit
cuz I
just I was
uh just I don't know it was the only
thing that I had to Hope on
but I quit that
too drugs isn't the solution to
everything I mean as much as I've been
through you'd figure I would be out here
doing the same thing but I just don't
see a use of pointing
drugs and I really wish that that would
clear up too yeah I mean such a
beautiful
area yeah you know you think there's you
know there's hunting there's fishing
there's nature around you
everywhere until you go to the city and
then you see somebody walking and
nodding out on the street and stuff that
that's
so it's just a lot of people I'm I'm
sure there's people out there that's
going through some stuff too just as bad
as I've went through it but that's why I
kind of wanted to be videoed CU I want
people to know that
um bullying isn't isn't the solution to
people and and everyone should love each
other and I have no I have no flaws
against anyone of any type of race or
anything I I love everybody it's the way
it is it's the way it's supposed to be
it's the way God made things you
know yeah I mean these people that are
picking on people for whatever reason
whether they're like the Whitakers or or
somebody who just went through something
like what you did as a
kid it's just such a Mindless cruel
destructive thing to do yes it is and
you have to live with that the rest of
your life I I just think it messes with
your karma pretty bad I mean I feel like
that I mean God makes God has special
people in this world and those special
people belong to God and and uh no one
should ever have make fun of them or
make fun oh you got a Bo hanging anybody
oh
oh here let me wipe it
little that's what d are far yeah here
wrap that up until I can get you
backrow I have my oldest son he's
U he's 10 his name's Tav then U I got a
8-year-old named Brentley then I got uh
five oh a six-year-old named Luca and
then there's him he's five and his
name's
Asher and uh
another thing with me losing my job is
uh it's breaking my kids is hard
honestly cuz I don't I don't know what
I'm going to do about Christmas or
anything right and then the the
emotional strain on you yeah yeah it's
got to be
depressing yeah it's it's scary I try to
hold it together and I don't I don't
really like start crying from people but
real men do cry on their own time and
and I'm I I've cried a
lot it's just I just want the world to
know that instead of like making fun of
someone it don't even have to be me if
it's somebody out there in desperate
need
if if you got to make you shouldn't have
to make fun of somebody cuz you don't
know what they're going through in life
and I've been one of the strong ones you
could be making fun of somebody and you
could take somebody's life
because some people don't have Str to go
through something like that because then
they're going to want to hurt theirself
or end up
dead so if they're bullying people then
you need to think about what you're
doing to someone before you you say
something to
someone you know what I'm saying yeah
how long did it go on with uh with the
the molestation or is it just one time
it was one time yeah one time all it
takes
my it took him a month to notic see we
all was so little I didn't I didn't I
mean I remember I remember a lot but I
remember going into going into
Huntington with test and I remember
telling my mom what happened
um and they went and done test and they
physically found out it I'd been messed
with and they had took me uh to those
appointments and they had press charges
and they had picked him up about a month
after this happened but this didn't only
happen to me the he a week after this
happened to me he had done something
with his little sister H and she had
told the same same thing so and he's in
prison still I think he's out now but he
pulled from the time he was 16 to 21 in
juvenile detention and 21 to 25 in
prison but I feel like it should have
been something more because I don't
believe in that and especially doing
that to a little kid uh honestly people
like that needs the death penalty for
that I don't believe in
that yeah I don't know if I don't know
how reformable they are yeah I mean I
couldn't ever imagine messing with a
little kid like C me and if somebody did
that to my kids I I'd be really
defensive I don't know what I'd do yeah
I mean I I love my
kids and yeah I got four
boys I ain't had no girls
but I
just
basically uh have had a rough life with
having to deal with that and I right now
I I I really don't have many friends I
mean you can't really trust nobody they
all either turn on you or it's a they
act like your friend and and and behind
your back they're legit just making fun
of you what what percentage of people
your age
are clean to you know from drugs or not
using out
here there's not very big percentage I'd
say there's probably like 15 to
20% that are not using they're not using
wow this world
is I don't know it's become
dark and I
mean I wouldn't I I I wouldn't never do
drugs I mean I don't see the point in it
I don't I know I've seen a lot of my
friends die from drugs
and well the ones that was my friends uh
I didn't have very many though but I've
seen people that I've known die from
drugs and it's not a solution that you
need to take a road why why do you think
there are so many people out here that
that take the
drugs either they're probably going
through a
situation like I'm going through
or
they just
want like they're not having they're not
being
uh I can't find the word stimulated yeah
they're not being stimulated or they're
not getting provided enough like it
seems like there's not much to do out
here yeah there's not a lot to do out
here I've even sat and thought about
that I mean I feel like that they should
do that the government or something
should put something more hair for
people to do like like they have other
places like I mean there's hunting and
stuff here and like hunting clubs and
you got the ski resort up top but maybe
something like a amusement park or
something here in West Virginia or
something maybe would help like so kids
don't get bored and want to just sit
around and like cuz it's going to start
it's going to start by them drinking and
doing marijuana that's the first
solution and then they want more after
that and
I mean they wonder why people is on
these drugs because maybe if they would
put something here in West Virginia to
like amuse people like I mean and I mean
this is like one of the poorest states
in in the US right now I think this this
area is probably the poorest yeah and
it's just crazy I mean Beckley is is
like one of the
most moving building cities around why
can't they put something in for people
to like be amused on I mean a zoo or
something like that so people can go out
and like enjoy life like I mean we enjoy
it
but I
mean there's really nothing here to do
like at all I mean there's fourwheeler
riding and stuff but I'm sure that
there's people out there wants to do
something more that just haven't like
don't have a way to like travel or
something I feel like that's one of the
reasons why people get on drugs too is
cuz the place is basically dead and then
there's cities around here that's
falling down like mands and
Mata areas like that it's has all these
old buildings in it they need to just
wipe all that out and rebuild it like
rebuild stuff what do you think your
four sons are going to be doing in in 15
years I hope it ain't drugs or anything
I mean it runs it runs in their side the
family their her their mom's uh mom's uh
people are are strung down on stuff too
yeah you have to I try to keep my kids
away from it but I mean I don't want
them
to I don't want them to like not be able
to see their family but I don't want
them around that to where they know hey
let's pick this up and do this I I mean
but by living here they're surrounded by
it yeah while their friends are going to
be doing it yeah I know and it's going
to be a hard situation I honestly want
out of here like I want being a
different I like I mean I love it here
but in a way it's just West Virginia
it's like it's like it's dead is there's
nothing to do I mean and people get
bored and then they just end up doing
stupid stuff or end up on drugs and they
find drugs to they find drugs to be
Amusement like cuz the way I guess it
switches their mindset and they they see
see the place different but I don't know
I just wish that people wouldn't do
drugs honestly but I wish that the
government or something would build
something or make West Virginia a better
place somehow to
maybe help it not be so boring and
lonely you want to head back yeah we can
can it's kind of cold out here it is
cold it's like 33° one of us you W come
on
boy but
um other than that I just I just wish
that this state would quit the drugs and
and I wish that people wouldn't bully
people because they don't know what kind
of impact they're making on people's
lives or what kind of situation people
are in is a lack of Education part of
that whole I mean
problem someone I wish people would uh
not would try to enforce their kids like
to go to school and I wish they could
teach them and I wish that they would
step up and do a little bit more for the
kids like like teach them a little bit
better um honestly and I wish they would
make it a law to where they couldn't
drop out I mean I know that's bad but
brand and Lewis both I think only have
like ninth grade
education I mean I'm I graduated but I
graduated through homebound on my own
because of Bu The Bullying oh is that
right you I went into Homebound and I
done
homebound from ninth ninth grade all the
way through 12th but I got my diploma
were there things you dreamed about
doing when you were a young man I wanted
to I wanted to weld but I couldn't
finish my w i i was like two semesters
from finishing welding uh trade school
when I left the school I think I left in
10 grade
actually I'm pretty sure um I left the
school and went and gotten home um and
they wouldn't let me finish my Welding
which is wrong I wish like I wish they
could have let me finish my welding
because um my uncle is actually a uh
boss at the shipyard in norick Virginia
and he hires people to weld and they
make pretty good money and I didn't get
to finish that see if a good know a uh
teacher or a person that's trying to
help a
student they would jump in and be like
yeah we're going to help him finish his
trade but no they didn't so politically
they need to step up their game around
here to get kids to finish school so
they won't end up on drugs and they'll
have a better
life can you have you traveled have you
been around the country I've only been
to surrounding areas I've been to like
Tennessee
uh
Virginia and I've been to Pittsburgh
once yeah those are all pretty similar
economies to this yeah yeah you know if
you went to Miami or New York or Chicago
or Atlanta I haven't never been out of I
Haven never been that far away yeah but
if you if you're exposed to it you might
see the opportunities that it would give
you and your sons yeah things like
that yeah I I wish I could the world's a
big place yeah it is I just it's hard to
get a step up like when you haven't got
like a push and people are always at
your back because of your
past and it's hard to it's hard to do
anything especially when I've got four
kids and I mean I'm still live I'm 29
years old and I'm still having to live
with my mom and my sister is still
staying with my mom too um and my
dad but it's kind of my dad's in and out
basically but he he he's
uh they're both on disabled Social
Security they try to help me out as much
as possible but my dad got a in a car
wreck in like 2005 a doctor hit him in
Washington DC and and messed his back up
and my mom has her knees she needs two
total knee replacement
and it's just bad because I mean I I
have to help them and they're grout she
and grumpy and they really want to live
the rest of their life and I can't I
can't like I want to get out of their
home but it's so hard are you are you
concerned about leaving your parents
behind here if you were to move I mean I
want to leave I I I want to leave I want
to get out of their house I mean I want
to be able to come and see them and
stuff it's just that I want them to have
their own little life before like you
know they die and stuff you know and
I feel like I'm in the way like cuz I'm
having to live there with my kids and I
mean I that shouldn't ever had to be the
occasion if if people
would people would have stepped up and
done their job
and and been able to like help me get my
trade and all that like the schools they
should have stepped up and done more
just like for other people they should
have stepped up and done
more
and and I feel I mean I know it's our
own lives
but and the people making fun of people
like now I mean not only I'm struggling
but there's other people that's been
made fun of too and people that's went
to drugs and they're either dead or
they're out here strung out and they're
struggling
so really people need to just like stop
bashing people and they need to uplift
them instead of going and putting them
down I agree a
th% it's just it's hard for me now I
can't I can't get a push in my life
because of
it I can't even can't even move out my
parents' house
uh I'm a hard worker i h I had my own
vehicle but when I lost my job it's Pro
I'm probably going to lose my vehicle
I'm in a rental right now what's your
what's your biggest fear
biggest fear probably losing one of my
kids it's my biggest
fear cuz I mean they're my world I mean
losing one like custody you mean well be
honest with you
man
going I lost I lost a baby being her
lost a baby nine months ago died at
Birth
from
what was it the placenta
preia that hurt me bad and I mean
actually let me put you down a minute
I'm going to show him something I do got
a lot of
tattoos his name was
Broan he was a full-blown baby and we
had to we had to cremate
him
and it's really took a toe on me and my
her life and I mean that's kind of I
don't know I guess that's why we was
having problems too U and we got a
divorce and
stuff but we're trying to work things
out but losing a
kid it
really really touches you man I
mean I mean it it's it's hard cuz me I I
held I held the baby and everything
whenever
he I
just
know I wish it wouldn't ever happened
honestly it's one of the biggest fears
I've ever had it happen that's your
shivering yeah I'm G to get him back
let's take him
in I
just and I carry his ashes I have a
necklace that has his ashes in it I mean
it was the easiest way to go cuz I
didn't have much money at the time I
mean my my aunts and family helped out a
little bit but it's just I've been
through a a rough road a really rough
road and
it's we're all having to stay in a my
parents live in a single wide trailer
and I'm having to stay
there with three of my kids and then you
got Brandon and Gabby and their two kids
and it's just all bunched up really I
mean we I mean we all have beds and
stuff but
it's just really hard to have to live
like that you know it's a lot of people
in a trailer
yeah I just want to I just want to be
able to do more and change change my
life
honestly and I want better for my
kids I love I love them and I I wouldn't
ever dream to have to lose a kid but I
ended up losing one but if I lost if I
lost one like I I know it'd be
different cuz if I had to if I lost one
of my kids whether it be dying or them
being taken
or something like that that would that
would additionally break me in half like
I would I I probably fall over
myself I just want better for my kids
and that's why I was working that's why
I was trying to work but when people
were taunting you you can't you can't
really work cuz
if you're not bothering someone why
bother them why why come at them and
that's why I don't understand why the
world's so
dark I don't understand why people want
to bully
people you need to make a people need to
make a change they need to step up and
realize that not that everybody's having
the best
life and that's basically it that's all
I can say all right Sean thank you so
much for sharing your story you're
welcome I wish you all the luck in the
world thank you thank you
man
ready